have you ever noticed that some
restaurants have a bowl of mints by the
door and some give you a mint with your
bill it's not just a nice gesture but
it's actually a powerful psychological
principle to increase profits Studies
have shown that when a bill is given
with a mint customers give three percent
more in tips when two minutes are
handled with the bill tips increase by
14 but the most effective version of
this principle was when one man was put
on the platter and the server walked
away only to turn around and put another
mint back on there and when they did
that tips increased by a whopping 23
percent this phenomenon is known as
reciprocity when someone receives
something unexpected they feel obligated
to return the favor so if you're looking
for ways to increase sales start handing
out something to your customers before
they make a perching decision